you asked to see the boss I'm Johnny
Deng the king of plane is he under rocks
[Music]
my father and my grandfather's were
Julis so in Vietnam when I grow up
saw them how to make jewelry so that's
got in my mind about your business my
dad you know he's kept from Vietnam by
the boat so he sponsor us me and my my
brother and my mom so we came all family
came here 1996 I've been in Houston
since in that day when I came here I
went to work in flea market and a
jewelry repairs have two flea market I
open in garage like a small kind of
workshop I started ii stopped in they
called a shop tomorrow
a Southside Houston that's the way I
really started to do custom jewelry for
hip-hop I got into the program is just
because I started to work for the
dentist some people they want permanent
grill so they need to go to the dentist
to get a goal and the customer request
him to put diamond for the grill
so I I thought to myself okay I can do
to go and a diamond together too
I've been making so many grills with a
clan we're not a leader the ocean racing
like Snoop hawa he daddy Ric taught me
go and in the younger new generation
triple red little pom-pom have like four
different set of grill he want like to
set back-to-back this is one of football
player can Milton I met him in Atlanta
when it was Super Bowl so I make the
impression from any customer and then I
kept this one in the shop so whenever
they want second crew I just get the
more I'll do second grade just Travis
Scott last week I said hey Johnny I need
a plane for my birthday
moon today later I got a brand new set
for him whenever they need new jewelry
they just call me I
so quick because a lot of judo names
middleman or middleman you know say they
actually don't really make a jewelry
that's a make meats that are different
because we have my own manufacturer here
faster process most cheap on the price
and smallest piece we finish in like two
three days nobody get a cutting be done
in three days we could do it that's one
of the reason why all the rappers are
the client love me this is a whole
little group this is actually the blue
diamond the same 184 quaver when he
loved the song I strayed the game you
know so this whole ashtray you know it's
a second set from clever invisible
baguette if you want to hold a diamond
you must have the prompt so now I got a
prong hidden that's quite invisible set
you want a very tough look at this I can
make any kind of grill you can think of
using one of my bigger piece and we've
been watching the movie when it was a
kid so we so honor to be a part of the
movie so when I got a phone call from
the company you know to make the piece
out of this I'm saying man excited some
sit down with my team for a few days if
I got a software to create a 3d look
first they called a layout so I sit down
with a team I give them my idea draw it
out and so that's the first step to do
the design so and then we can have a 3d
core 3d printing so they make sure
slapping they run out of wax just a
machine to get this work cost like
somebody else jewelry store so after the
proact
we pour the go in that's a process
casting this is almost finished
we have a black diamond in here we have
a y diamond on this trim we will have a
blue like a diamond on the side so it
look like real
got Javas you know I'm saying the real
monster this already for $2,500
it might take another four or five
diamonds almost 10,000 diamond on one
piece this one almost $100,000 but as
our from food for me for manufacture
hotel if you walk to regular story they
do this light three four on the concept
but a lot of details take a lot of
diamonds this one would be a big piece
with the name under here gorillas and it
would be a real heavy unfinished go
that's how they look so when we finish
polishing they become good in the collar
go so this kind of unfinished I'm gonna
send you the grill picture after it's
done you see the real how beautiful it
looks
I have a crazy story above the movie
once it was in Vietnam you know when I
was to grow up we don't have a power nor
electric shade in my village
so nighttime in a whole village it dark
right one time I have one a dog I they
came they told us I get together I show
you the movie they don't have no movie
theater they wouldn't die a toy and they
solder the lie in the back to show to
the wall like the movie walk them and
say do see Godzilla that's had a monster
move
baby hit me up say hey I won the piece
and I won wonderful my partner too but I
gonna so we just got this one done real
heavy a thousand or diamond so they just
look like a book cover this one I just
trust him on 45,000 years this is
actually the goal but on the top which
to do the enamel color on the top and on
so I do a lot of fun young dog and this
is a nudist one I just finished for him
he won't look at the bucket what you
know say the bucket Patek Phillipe was
blue diamond and have a cognac diamond
red rubies and why diamonds the real one
of the tails this one about like 55
hours
this my myself my first cutting people
long time there's my personal piece I
got Johnny down here with a grill in
there JD black and white diamond it's
it's kind of like my look in KATU way I
make this on by all hang back Nancy make
there are no computer yet so I had met
all this detail so he's like 15 years
old piece but I love that where is out
of time
this is one of the link that we created
to mess with the piece but you don't see
this a lot because there's they got
yellow blue diamond actually a lot of
people offered me to buy it but I don't
want to sell it they gotta wear just one
of my first big it beast when I started
become the big cureless this is just me
for one of my clients I have a lot of
regular clients they place a lot of big
order like this they not a big man but
they spent a lot of money on cuts and P
these are there's two piece I met for to
chance to change self with us for a long
time and I've been making like 20 30
piece lady because he have a lot of
artists and get to away for the team I
have about 30 of those laying around
here they're a big shout out to teach
hands every piece in my favorite piece
I love this one because the combination
between baguette and brow diamond so
easily take like 25 carat diamond just
like 35,000 the reason baguette costs a
little more when you could a baguette
you waste a lot of rough of diamond
that's why the baguette cause a little
more special than crowd I mean this is
one of diamond Belvoir curtsy King no
planes or everything I saw this is like
$20,000 bad worker cost more than my
shoot of course you know to to get the
name king of plane to start is really
from the bottom I came from Vietnam and
to be a king of bling and ask all
Americans dream it's really stream come
to you know do you thinking about any
custom jewelry any piece come to me king
of bling Johnny Day